charlie morton is on the mound for the
braves he needs a good start needs a
deep start for the braves tonight yeah
we'll talk a minute about one of my keys
a couple things to look at opponents
here in 329 off his sinker and cutter
chip
the left-handers hit 103 off the curve
ball and paired it for charlie to be
able to throw that ball for a strike
this is 22 year old dylan carlson this
one on the ground to freeman to hopper
and horton to the bag another perfect
feed by freddie freeman got the ball to
morton where he still had about three
steps to get to the base and find it
easily perfectly executed we've seen
that so many times so paul goldschmidt
is the batter the pitch
is tapped back to the mound and boy
charlie morton needed that easy one two
three first inning down go the cardinals
the braves will face john gantz a former
brave so gant making his first start at
truest park since being traded by the
braves to the cardinals in december of
2016 for jaime garcia ronald acuna jr
will lead it off the o2 pitch
swaying and a miss and a strikeout for
gant to start his game acuna stuck on 99
career home runs
homerless
seven consecutive games yeah well that
was a really good change up back-to-back
change-ups by john gantt and again for
for a right-hander to be able to throw
that pitch it's impressive freddie
freeman
swinging on 3-0 keep it fair they will
and goldie steps on the bag well thank
you yes
this is ozzie albee's switch hitter
and lines it into right and the catch
made by tommy edmond a one two three
inning for john gantz so here's tyler
o'neill now two and two swing and a miss
he chased that ball darting down and
away and morton has his first strikeout
great curveball good action so strikeout
76 for morton in 67 innings and here's
giadio molinos two outs in the second
and molina chased a high fastball and
morton six up six down with a couple of
punch-outs home second coming up no
score at home austin reilly there's a
one-two pitch
got him with a changeup and the second
strikeout for john gant tonight here's
dansby swanson
backhanded
the turn and out at first it's a double
play
john gant if it sticks that would be the
ninth double play on the ground behind
him
he's always got that pitch there in the
pocket that's sinker bottom of the zone
he gets him
so the six four three double play no
score dylan carson
he hits another batter back foot
breaking ball
second hit batsman carlson aboard to
lead off the cardinal fourth when i said
the curveball's biting jeff that's not
what i had in mind another hit by pitch
for charlie morton so that's nine this
season as you know if there has been an
issue for charlie morton he has
struggled with runners in scoring
position he struggled with men on base
and now he's got to face the three four
five hitters for st louis including paul
goldschmidt
chopper hit toward riley at third second
base for one another long throw double
play that takes care of that morton
retired it's on a good pace working
quick so here's arenado and a 3-2 pitch
morton gets aronado he came back from a
3-0 count elevated the heater again with
great effect that's five strikeouts for
morton guillermo herrera popped out his
first time up he's been on base in eight
of his last 14 played appearances two
and two as this one is hammered toward
left 2-2 pitch deep toward that wall it
is gone the braves get a two-strike hit
a big fly from guillermo heredia
and atlanta has broken through
first right-handed
home run allowed
by john gant this year one-nothing
braves we've talked how good of a job
he's done all night of keeping the ball
low chip you're gonna see here on this
change of first one he really left
letter high
in a game that not much is going on
right now
get the braves on the board look at that
that one just hung all his other ones
have been down in the zone on bono
strikes
for the braves first baseman acuna leads
it first he's taken off pitch is in the
dirt molina's throw is high and ronald
steals his 14th taking a look that he
came off the base maybe hand came off it
was the leg on it the whole time let's
see deyoung kept the tag on acuna the
hand came off let's see from this angle
tag on the
no
i think his toe is
his fingertip was still holding the bag
on the back enough till that foot came
on be a lot to ask the cuny had contact
with the base yeah and there wasn't
enough to overturn it when his hand
finally came off his foot was on the
base at that point
ozzy over two with a fly out to right
and a fly out to left
infield in so a lot of holes to shoot at
cash this in oh and two still
lined in the left center field he did
it's a base hit that'll score acuna ozzy
on his way to second helmet flying he'll
make the turn he's chugging for three
here comes the throw it is late making
an rbi triple two nothing brave well
what do we say chip do your job ronald
got on base stole freddy got him over
ozzy got a break with him not catching
that ball
split the gap and look at this he was
right thinking three the whole time so
that's gonna be the final pitch thrown
by john gant three defenders on the
right side for almonte who's walked and
bounced into a force play daniel ponce
de leon is on for st louis hit hard out
to right field down the line towards the
wall that is off the wall in the scores
ozzie making a double out of abraham and
almonte makes it a three-nothing braves
lead here in the sixth waves have come
alive here in the sixth inning now
you've got gold schmidt and arenado get
through these two guys then you start
thinking about a bigger picture than a
three-nothing lead
lined out to center field in a base hit
what a battle goldsmith with a very
first base into the ball game for the
cardinals so morton's no hit bid
ends here in the seventh there's no way
paul goldschmidt should still have been
alive to get that hit
just doesn't just doesn't figure charlie
morton is the story tonight a no-hit bid
into the seventh inning goldschmidt
spoil that but arenado
just popped out for number two in the
inning
and here is o'neill there's another
three-two's on the way strike three
called o'neill is rung up he can't
believe it he's over three morton with a
shutout through seven three nothing is
your score it's time for the stretch
three and two hit that ball of the
outfield two free rbi waiting for you
get this run in
swung on and barrel high in the air to
deep left center field back towards the
warning track goes carlson on the track
he makes the catch that is plenty deep
enough to score the run
a sacrifice fly for ronaldo cunha scores
guillermo haradia four-nothing braves
and rbi number 43 on the season for
acuna
nolan arenado stands in the way of a
four nothing shutout
high pop fly can anybody catch up dansby
long run near the line he's there he's
got it what a way to end it and the
braves open up the weekend in shutout
fashion partner four-nothing